-Today Dr. Christine Blasey Ford
testified to the Senate
about the allegations
of sexual assault against
Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Coming into this hearing today,
President Trump's aides
desperately tried
to restrain him
and prevent him
from attacking Dr. Ford,
but Trump very quickly
dispensed with that advice
and went on the offensive.
In fact, Trump was
apparently so frustrated
by the growing crisis
around his nominee
that he decided to take matters
into his own hands.
-President Trump is not only
still standing by
Judge Brett Kavanaugh,
but tonight,
he's taking the reins
of defending the embattled
Supreme Court nominee.
He's grown increasingly
dissatisfied
with how Kavanaugh
has defended himself,
CNN has learned.
-The president believes
on the eve
of this hearing in the Senate
that he and he, alone,
can put the best spin on this,
that he can defend his nominee.
-Oh, good.
Trump is taking charge now.
That's like if
your computer froze
and your grandpa was like,
"Let me see that thing.
You probably just need
more water in the keyboard."
That's why Trump held his insane
press conference yesterday.
He actually thought
he was helping
when, for example,
he went off on an insane
and totally unrelated tangent
about how the Chinese
think he's smart.
-If you look at Mr. Pillsbury,
the leading authority on China,
he was on a good show --
I won't mention the name
of the show -- recently.
And he was saying that China has
total respect for Donald Trump
And for Donald Trump's
very, very large a-brain.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a-sorry?
Why is he doing
a bad Italian accent?
Is he quoting a China expert,
or Super Mario?
[ As Mario ] It's me, a-Mario.
Donald Trump has a large brain.
Also, I think he's quoting
someone he saw on cable news
named Mr. Pillsbury,
but I also feel like
there's a decent chance
he just saw a commercial
with the Pillsbury Doughboy
and then he hallucinated
that it was talking to him.
-You have a very,
very large brain.
Hoo-hoo-hoo!
-[ As Trump] Thank you,
Mr. Pillsbury,
for your kind words
and your delicious biscuits.
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
Trump's frantic paranoid attempt
to defend his embattled
Supreme Court nominee
from sexual-assault allegations
led him to a truly crazy place.
Somehow, he found a way
to drag George Washington
into his mess.
-Look, if we brought
George Washington here,
and we said,
"We have George Washington,"
the Democrats would
vote against him.
Just so you understand.
-I mean,
does he still own slaves?
Then, yeah.
Democrats would
vote against him,
And Republicans
would probably say,
"Hey, man, everybody owned
a few slaves in college.
You want to ruin his life
over it?"
Trump actually kept going
because then he seemed to imply
that George Washington
had something nefarious
in his background
that we don't know about.
-And he may have had a bad past.
Who knows, you know?
He may have had some...
I think, accusations made.
Didn't he have a couple things
in his past?
-Wait.
Did Trump just imply
that George Washington was
as shady as he is?
"I hear he chopped down
a cherry tree
and then he used that tree
to pay off a porn star."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Only Trump.
Only Trump would try
to defend himself
by slandering another president.
"So what if I cheated
on my wife?
Abraham Lincoln left his wife
right in the middle of play."
[ Laughter ]
"What? what happened?
Oh, okay.
I didn't read the whole book."
So Trump and Republicans
had already made clear
that their intent
was to protect Kavanaugh
and dismiss Dr. Ford.
And in the hearing today,
Republicans picked up
right where Trump left off.
Before Dr. Ford even
uttered a single word,
Iowa senator Chuck Grassley
delivered
an exhausting monologue
defending Kavanaugh
and slamming Democrats.
And then after ranting
for almost 15 minutes,
Senator Grassley finally
turned the mic over
to the senior Democrat
on the committee,
Dianne Feinstein.
Only to interrupt her
one minute later.
-Before you get
to your testimony,
and the chairman chose
not to do this,
I think it's important
to make sure
you're properly introduced.
-By the way, I was
going to introduce her,
but if you want
to introduce her,
I'll be glad
to have you do that.
But I want you to know
I didn't forget to do it,
because I would do that
just as she was about to speak.
-You said I didn't do it,
but I'm going to do it.
And then you did it
and now I can't do it
because it's done.
Dude, shut up.
Your time is up.
You don't get to pop up
out of your coffin
whenever you want,
like The Crypt-Keeper.
I was going to do it,
then you did it!
[ Applause ]
And yet the Republicans'
constant sniping
and their obvious attempts
to obstruct the process
and brush Ford aside
did not deter her in any way.
Her testimony today was
a towering act of courage
given the trauma she's survived.
Her grace and composure
under unimaginable pressure
which she owed no one
was stunning.
In fact, at one point, Dr. Ford,
a research psychologist,
literally explained to the panel
how memory works.
-How are you so sure
that it was he?
-The same way that I'm sure
that I'm talking to you
right now.
Just basic memory functions.
And also just the level
of norepinephrine
and epinephrine
in the brain
that sort of, as you know,
encodes that neurotransmitter,
encodes memories
into the hippocampus.
-She's in the middle
of testifying
in the intense glare
of the national spotlight
about an alleged sexual assault
committed by
a Supreme Court nominee
and she just taught everyone
how the brain works.
She gave a detailed anatomy
of the hippocampus
and the memory centers
in the brain
to a roomful of guys
who look like they eat brains.
Seriously, just think about --
Think about how impressive
that is.
She's a research psychologist
explaining how the mind works
in the middle
of a horrific experience
that no one should
ever have to endure.
Meanwhile, the most
coherent thing
Trump has ever said about
the mind is that he has a...
-Very, very large a-brain.
[ Laughter ]
-in fact, throughout
the hearing --
Throughout the hearing,
Republicans really had to scrape
the bottom of the barrel
to try to discredit Dr. Ford.
At one point, the prosecutor
Republicans picked
went down a confusing
line of questioning
about Dr. Ford's fear of flying,
Republicans have also
spent weeks falsely implying
that Dr. Ford was missing
key facts in her story.
But throughout this hearing,
it became clear that they were
the ones who had
basic facts wrong,
like when they asked her
about her travels to Australia.
-In fact, you fly
fairly frequently
for your hobbies,
and you've had to fly
for your work.
Is that true?
-Correct. Unfortunately.
-You were a consulting
biostatistician
in Sydney, Australia.
Is that right?
-I've never been to Australia.
But the company I worked for
is based in Australia.
-"You said you flew to Australia
to eat dinner?"
"Uh, no, I said I went
to an Outback Steakhouse."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And if you thought
the Republican attacks --
If you thought
the Republican attacks
couldn't get any dumber
and more desperate,
you were wrong
because you forgot
that there's a second
Donald Trump.
And he chimed in on Twitter
after the airplane question
to say this --
"I'm no psychology professor,
but it does seem weird to me
that someone could have
a selective fear of flying."
Oh!
Oh, you're not
a psychology professor?
Is that why you look
like a princess kissed
a double-parked BMW,
and it came to life?
Well, Dr. Ford literally is
a psychology professor,
you melted-down Beavis.
Dr. Ford's testimony was
so searing and so powerful
and so impressive
that Republicans were
clearly caught off guard.
In fact, even Fox News,
the network that spends all day
parroting Republican
talking points,
said Dr. Ford's testimony
was bad for the GOP.
-The court of public opinion,
if our colleague is
an adequate sample of it,
is that she is
extremely credible.
The president cannot
be happy with this.
-This was extremely emotional,
extremely raw,
and extremely credible.
This is a disaster
for the Republicans.
-Wow. You know it's a bad when
Fox News calls it a disaster.
Fox News will say anything
to make Republicans feel better.
If the Hindenburg had been
built by Republicans,
the Fox News headline
would have been this.
When it was Kavanaugh's turn,
he struck a much different tone
from his Fox News interview
earlier this week.
He was angry, defiant,
and stole a page
out of Trump's playbook
by claiming, with zero evidence,
that the allegations were part
of a left-wing conspiracy
to destroy him.
-Since my nomination in July,
there has been
a frenzy on the left
to come up with something,
anything,
to block my confirmation.
And millions of dollars in money
from outside left-wing
opposition groups.
This whole two-week effort
has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit
fueled with apparent
pent-up anger
about President Trump
and the 2016 election,
fear that has been
unfairly stoked
about my judicial record,
revenge on behalf
of the Clintons.
-Holy [bleep], I'm surprised
he didn't start attacking
George Washington.
"If he's so honest,
then why does he wear a wig?"
[ Laughter ]
You think this was a revenge
plot by the Clintons?
That's insane.
Republicans always act like
they're in a slasher film
and the killer
around every corner
is Hillary Clinton.
Republicans came
into this hearing
clearly trying to dismiss
and discredit Dr. Ford
and instead,
they encountered someone
who's immeasurable courage
shone through their attempts
to obstruct.
What we've seen this week
is a group of powerful men
trying to protect each other
from the consequences
of their actions.
And a woman who not only
told her story with
unimaginable bravery,
but also showed everyone
that she has a very large...
-A-brain.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]